kelly est ce que tu te rappelles de ta
première qui est mis dans les lycées je
me rappelle de ma première j'étais très
loin très loin de vous tous tout petit
comme ça et j'étais très stressée
énormément stressé parce qu'il fallait
que je passe de la musique et c'était
pas du tout mon délire alors est ce
qu'on peut voir la première de qualité
dvd au départ tu étais venu en djette
dans la nation tu faisais tout sauf
envoyer les musiques un pays stratégique
en huit ans sans rigoler en 200
émissions haladjian voyez une fois un
sou et pas erp et il continue t elle
qu'elle avait glissé sur la platine un
médecin gérard boyer a beau regarder
c'était le 4 septembre 2010 est il ya
trois ans dès mardi après que la police
note reach est cette fois que la
regardent ils appellent dans une pub
pour timothée sans déconner quelques
petites questions parce que je sais
qu'on va avoir beaucoup de gens sur
twitter sur bobo sur un stade qui vont
poser des questions et elle célibataire
oui ou non et elle célibataire je crois
bien que oui vous êtes célibataire
oui je viens de dire un pierre cd
j'adore chez qui lie l intime est
adorable
un petit clin absolument indécent
qu'est-ce que j'ai emmené à [ __ ] de
son insu de son mieux alors isabelle
maury loi qui va venir nous rejoindre si
tout à l'heure kelly est ce que tu te
rappelles de ton recrutement toi parce
que le recrutement de chacun c'est quand
même une barque et on va parler du
recrutement de matthieu delormeau ti
dans un instant ça a été une énorme
d'arca et alors qu'est discutera pas
toujours en croûte montauban mon
recrutement grosse d'arc a donc j'étais
dans paris avec un pote je me baladais
en voiture c'était cool
il y avait du soleil je partais bronzé
et là je reçois un message et à des
numéros que je connais pas et je reçois
salut kelly
c'est cyril est ce qu'on peut se voir
cinq minutes pour l'émission août à
autre chose à [ __ ] je me suis dit mais
qui souffre la journée l'agent me te
dirai c'est sur ces nuits de classe j'y
réfléchis et j'allais boire un verre
avec orchestre a dit la femme de jean
donc j'appelle orages dit rien ou films
envoyer un message
la dernière fava pour le téléspectateur
sera la dernière
ea mobile et kelly s'il est uni
ponctuent répondre moi j'allais pas
répondre qu'ils se droguent et elle me
dit que tu répondes est tous assez serré
pour les points rentrée prochaine
donc du coup je t'ai répondu et je t'ai
dis moi je crois que ça à [ __ ] donc on
va devoir avec tu m'avais parlé de ma
vie par les deux bouts en espagne et je
dis on va on va se voir tous les trois
et puis elle va détenir que ça s'est
fait comme ça
pas exactement on l'a vu avec ionel
stade et était venu avec un copain c'est
la seule bob qui vit en entretien
d'embauché avec un potin quand quelqu'un
regarde l'étape
le mec il d'un côté ils savaient pas ce
qu'ils faisaient voilà il était très
gentil d'ailleurs je suis toujours votre
pote mais en tout cas il était très
sympa voilà ainsi nous regarde je
l'embrassé voilà mais c'est vrai qu'elle
est venue avec un pote est ce que vous
avez envie de revenir djette ou est-ce
que vous préférez rester autour de la
table à table franchement je veux dire
juste un truc la vérité c'est que moi
j'ai galéré j'ai galéré pendant des
années
j'avais pas spécialement de buts mais je
le voulais faire quelque chose parce que
je me disais que ben j'avais envie de
dire des choses j'avais envie de parler
j'avais envie de dire des choses et je
trouvais pas un petit peu ce que ce que
je voulais faire de ma vie j'ai fait la
musique du chant de la danse je voulais
m'exprimer et je me rends compte pour le
jour où j'ai reçu ce texto de ouf
eh ben je me dis que ça a changé ma vie
et j'ai rencontré des personnes de ouf
gb toute once de substitution de malade
j'ai trouvé jean louis dans ma vie gg
gilles dans ma vie c'est vraiment des
jets des frères des nouveaux frères gmac
c'est benjamin g vous cyr et le
maintenant j'ai vraiment les voitures
merci merci merci je t'aime à l'ériger
jésus dit il j'ai plein de monde y est
j'ai izard et je me dis que j'ai d'avoir
rencontré cette nouvelle famille pour
moi c'est juste un truc trouvent parce
que je suis présentement et j'ai trop de
sentiments quand tout le monde et je
vous aime trop